You should have gotten one eighth of a foot candle. Fantastic work for figuring
that one out. We want to start by setting up our proportion using inverse
variation. We know the intensity of light varies inversely as the square of the
distance. This means that for intensity one, the distance one needs to be
squared in the denominator. We flip the second fraction. Now I think it's really
easy to make a mistake when plugging in these amounts. So I would make a list of
the amounts and then write in the numbers or variables that go with them. We
know intensity one is two-foot candles, and that's at a distance of five feet
away. So intensity one is two-foot candles, and the distance one is five feet.
We're looking for the second intensity. We don't know it so we use x. And this
intensity occurs at 20 feet from the light source. So we have 20 feet for our
second distance. We can use this list to help us plug in the values to get this
proportion. We'll leave two divided by x here, and then we'll have 400 divided
by 25 here. We cross-multiply to get 50 equals 400 x, and then we divide both
sides by 400. To get x is equal to 1 8th, 1 8th is this equivalent fraction. We
simply divide each number by 50. We saw for an intensity of light so we want to
make sure we put the correct unit. It was 1 8th foot candles.